do you need yeah do you need to use dark
mode for everything yes I use dark mode
because I'm not an [ __ ] I just think
light mode looks like [ __ ] yeah it's
like and also I don't want to be that
guy while I'm lying in bed and my
partner is next to me
there's literally no the only way the
light mode is good is like because the
windows UI looks like [ __ ] let me see
let me you dark mode [ __ ] play
[ __ ] up too much okay hi I'm I'm a light
mode user yes I'm I'm out of myself
right now okay that's probably why your
eyesight [ __ ] yeah yeah because you're
blinding yourself every night I've been
blind my entire life What's it gonna do
make me more you'll literally like make
me more blind every time you open up
Twitter it's just like a Cod flash Banks
come on it's white don't let the view it
is it is the people who use light mode
are people who do Psychopaths can't
can't get over the five second
difference of changing the dark mode and
be like it's different people
foreign
like some apps and I'm like I like 10
seconds 10 seconds Discord that's it my
Discord is still dark mode and I'm like
yeah I don't I don't Discord in light
mode is unforgivable I don't even know
what this okay the light mode looks like
okay this mod live mode just looks ugly
that just looks like let's see it's
horrific but like everything else I've
switched to dark mode I'm like I kind of
I like the price I like the brightness I
do not use Twitter in I looked up
Discord light mode
do you actually want to check my Twitter
oh my God so ugly dude
who uses Discord like this yeah okay
discord's ugly Twitter Twitter I I like
it in like mode okay I can't remember if
there was a few studies or something a
while back that was like I it was
measuring the impact on which ones
better for you darker light mode I
couldn't remember if there's a
conclusion I remember that there was
something along the lines of
um what light mode is could be better
because it's more reminiscent of say
books or paper yeah because I was gonna
say like Joey like you you looked like
I'm in bed okay I want to read manga
yeah what am I gonna do switch the manga
to dark mode manga doesn't have a dark
mode you know Read Manga in my [ __ ]
phone
um
one of the big reasons I can't because
it's too bright and I would I would
argue that a lot of manga is more dark
than light a lot of the drawing is black
it's literally on white paint what are
you talking about yeah
it's on white paper but there's more ink
on the paper than white what do you do
foreign
[Music]
person is watching this bite now being
like no Connor I'm trying my best
I I think there's saying the manga
argument is very negligible in terms of
is that light mode or not because
there's gonna be some we're not saying
dark we're not [ __ ] knocked over yeah
who the [ __ ] it's not all dark
what we're trying to say is that
generally like the background and a lot
of that stuff is dark which is nice and
it's better because the phone is backlit
you know well the thing is because like
it's not traditional the reason I
genuinely like light mode is because
you've never tried dark mode I have
tried dark mode no I I okay the best
actually the best mode is the one where
it switches for you automatically
depending on the time of day because the
thing is I wake up screen dimmer yeah
the screen no not the screen dimmer
there's a little there's a literal mode
that will switch on on some apps that
will switch from light mode to dark mode
like an in-car GPS yeah yeah yeah kind
of that's like the best mode but like I
like when I wake up and I just have like
the brightness of the screens okay one
thing I genuinely generally welcome to
your future robot slaves look genuinely
because I'm someone who needs a lot of
sunshine you know I I like my sunshine I
like I like my brightness the way my
body oh we get it guys you touch grass
I also enjoy sunlight but you know what
I do when I want to enjoy sunlight I
[ __ ] go outside and look at something
okay open my curtain okay
obviously you guys have obviously you've
never lived in England when sometimes
it's just like a [ __ ] cloudy day and
it's just the most the best
I would not live in like the northern
hemisphere of like Finland in the middle
[ __ ] nowhere
I will take any brightness Source I can
get the brighter the room is the happier
I am the more awake I am the more that's
probably why you're blind because you're
just flash banging your eyes every day
okay phone's likeness is not even
remotely comparable to a light in say
like a room like a ceiling light or
anything it's not even remotely also
take a result
sorry they also take every selfie with
the flash on no no
just be a bunch of [ __ ] phone screens
just lighting up the room like what
these lights are totally different type
of like I I do not want the artificial
it's like I want white walls in my room
I feel so much nicer
sunlight does feel so much nicer but
sometimes you're in a room where you
can't get enough sunlight sometimes
you're in a place where you know there
isn't enough natural light and there's
just the lighting on the ceiling or the
lamps the last Light I think about
getting to fix that problem is my phone
okay yeah I will say having having like
having a bright mode on your PC is much
better to me like it it feels for the
argument's sake I do use Windows Live
mode yeah because the dark mode I don't
know what they did to it it looks
[ __ ] horrendous really yeah do you
use it and I use I didn't even know
there was a dog it just doesn't look
good I'm not sure why oh like it's all
it's it try it we'll do it later okay I
mean what looks bad about light mode
what what actually I don't get what are
you why everyone and says it looks bad
okay it's just really it's like having
like bread from a store and then you
know and like you don't know a bakery
exists out there fresh bread right right
you're really clutch it does white light
mode does everything it's it's a very
viable option but it's just because you
don't know about the joyous ability you
can't just say it it hurts my eyes no no
it doesn't no because it does it hurts
my eyes I just think dark mode
that's exactly what I'm saying dark mode
it looks better that's what we have
after dark because it's a better version
of trash
just a dark version of trash test this
disgusting this is uh this is light mode
sorry if you a lot of the apps just like
I Twitter to me is is I I can't unsee it
as a dark Mode app it just it when I see
it on light mode I'm like this is
[ __ ] like when you watch those
documentaries and that you know they
play all like the millions of tweets
pop-up and they have the white
background I'm like it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
bro we sold more after dark merch than
we did Regular trash days motion
coincidence I think not people like dark
mode people like the vibe but there's a
shirt there is people not light I know
it's not reflected well you're wearing
the light mode one man you got white
there Connor what are you doing does
that hurt your eyes yeah
is that apps are better in dark mode
yeah you're on I rest my case
there I think there is a sect of us
light mode users we have been oppressed
by the dark mode
at least tell me okay okay of course
dark Mode's gonna work at least how do
you know that how do you know because
we're a [ __ ] weird
they first stay in the [ __ ] man caves
right yeah let's listen at least tell me
all right if you're if you're you know
you're in bed right you're just before
you go to bed I'm not the one fighting
you're gonna be yeah
you're gonna be you know you're gonna be
uh you know on your phone going through
Twitter and stuff like that before you
go to bed right you do that yes okay how
bright do you have your phone how bright
do I have like when it comes to the
brightness meter on your phone right
right is it all the way to the top or is
it all the way to the bottom or
somewhere in between well I try not to
go on my phone if if the room is dark
yeah if you're wearing a pitch black
room and you and you want to go on
Twitter before you go to bed how right
is your phone usually don't because okay
like to me like that's that's one way to
just not get asleep right right
also one way to have eyesight as well
well okay okay but I'm a bad phone
enjoyer I am as well I put my phone I
put my thing I put my Twitter on
document I put my bad habits oh my God
am I guilty of checking my phone yeah
sometimes yeah of course you're on it
okay I'm guilty yeah of course but I
seem like uh like an old Ox I sleep
great yeah great sleep yeah look I'm
saying it's it's a good habit just
because like it gets your mind in the
process of getting to sleep healthy
habits healthy habits
healthy from a guy who uses life I am
going to preach this okay I'm preaching
is right now Joey listen if I have any
healthy habits I'd stop drinking God
that's I don't care about that all right
I really don't care about that so you'd
rather you you'd rather you'd rather use
I think that's [ __ ] though what
you're saying is the healthiest way is
to not look at your phone what we're
arguing is uh well I'm not really oh
he's arguing him out here I'm I'm you
should look at the dark mode if you're
gonna look I'm arguing that the best
mode is the mode that switches
automatically automatically for you but
if I had a choice between dark mode and
light mode I choose light mode because I
don't want to switch manually to light
mode every time when I wake up in the
morning and see all the boys that you
don't like about dark mode what is it
that I don't like about dark mode it's
not that I don't like dark mode is that
I prefer light mode or why do you prefer
light mode I just I literally just said
because I I said because I like the
brightness in my life Joey I like this I
like the light okay I go towards the
light I'm a [ __ ] moth okay
I like the brightness why is that a bad
thing I like the brightness even darker
light mode light mode
everything everything you know
everything I think everything aside from
Discord because I see I think Discord
Discord is actually War crime I think we
can all agree on YouTube light mode uh
everything it's so bad in life
there's what is wrong with YouTube live
mode literally do what the [ __ ] logo
has white in it you know what a logo has
white in it it's like three pixels it
doesn't matter okay you know what I hate
about YouTube is that you open it right
so you open YouTube yeah and it does
okay I did win this up sometimes right
it'll just open white and then turn to
dark oh yeah
I want to see a single I think they
fixed that recently though but a lot of
people you know uh it's something going
to consider yourself if you're making
thumbnails yeah I gotta make it for dark
and light mode to make sure let's get on
both I've never thought about it I don't
I don't I don't consider like so do you
so yeah when you make your thumbnails do
you actually consider that no white
background no nothing I try not to make
it yeah I look at both because I had it
in dark mode so I gotta be because
people leave on the default right oh I
just assumed no one watches YouTube in
line mode
no it's default unfortunately yeah it
just means that our calls will never be
the best yeah I just I just don't I I
okay people are lazy and they just don't
change the defaults because they get
used to something and then they're too
scared to change it like this guy have
you changed it I guarantee you wouldn't
turn I have changed it I'm saying this
is not do not love me with the same
people who are still using Internet
Explorer because they don't have to
change like a little little science
experiment what if you change the dark
mode for a week I'll change the light
mode for a week and at the end we can
decide and see who has the better
eyesight
do you think there is a chance you're
going to convert to light mode
I I started in light mode and then I I
ironically I saw the light and I I
didn't like it so I went to the dark and
that's what I'm in narrative so I I've
had the light mode because where I
started yeah I mean I had the life and
then I learned about dark mode
afterwards and so I was like oh I'll try
this new dark mode thing out and I'll
say oh I much prefer because it doesn't
blind me every morning look I'm just
saying like [ __ ] light mode is the
pizza crust of the app world okay like
it feels exactly the same where you
where if you choose to use [ __ ] light
mode people act like you've just
committed a [ __ ] War crime or
something you know a war crime against
their eyes or something okay that's
that's what it feels like okay
all right what do you think uh is
winning right now in the poll I know
it's dark mode why do you think my stock
mode because it because you you dark
mode guides are so [ __ ] vocal about
it
you you dark mode users because I'm sick
of being on the [ __ ] train look
looking across on the person next to me
and they have [ __ ] light mode beaming
in my eyes you uncivilized [ __ ] you
stuck what is what look it doesn't
matter what the poll says I want to
guess 90 10. what do you think
probably United yeah do you think it's
that much maybe that's what okay that's
what I feel like I could have gone to my
head I'd have been like that's what I
feel like 40. really really what is it
now
um well let me um how long has the fall
feed off wait wait how how many 3 000
votes oh yeah 95 Darkness
so someone said okay which one of the
boys uses light mode confess your sin
someone replied it's gone Connor is
going to defend dog mode like his life
depends
Joey is gonna say I can see both sides
but prefers documents I feel so cool
down anyone who says light mode is a
sociopath look if there are 500 light
mode users in the world I am one of them
I am one of them if there are 10 live
mode users I am one of them I will
defend light mode until till my dying
breath okay I don't care how many of you
guys are there if there's one or more of
me of you if there's one more of me I
found a brother like an AAA meeting but
for light mode
why didn't we convert any time to like
flickers or anything
we're gonna start a movement it's a
revolution okay we're taking back the
rise mode the resistance
it's one of the things when I when I
realized that doctor was a thing I tried
it out I was like oh this is much better
it's like it's like having a wrong
fitting t-shirt for the longest time and
then you realize oh oh it can feel like
this that's what it felt like to change
right right like a pair of boxes that
didn't quite fit as nicely but you
didn't realize that so you're only pay
for everybody was the app that convinced
you was it Discord because I swear for
me it was Twitter Twitter I started off
with Twitter because I think
a lot of apps don't even tell you that
dark mode exists I didn't know it
existed me neither and then I think I
went on Twitter one day and they showed
the dark mode yeah they had dark like
true dark and like the dim darker Navy
dark I use that one love that one looks
amazing and then I thought hi what if
there's dark mode for other apps and one
time I shared my screen on Discord and
it was light mode I didn't even realize
dark mode existed and then all my live
stream people were like what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] no okay because like yeah
I was exactly the same so it was like
like I saw it on on Twitter and I was
like oh let me try this out and I was
like it's amazing
and I was like oh is that like a plug-in
or something what is that have you
realized about most screenshots you see
on Twitter or dark mode yeah it's like
tweet memes don't think about it yeah
think about it think about it
it doesn't matter how many it does like
I said where would I find cars
yeah I think I own my own thing if
everyone used talk mode [ __ ] do you
think people what they want that is that
is why take away that is why this is the
most depressed Society we've had in all
of history this is why this is the
depressed generation okay we haven't had
that yet okay this is why mental health
is such a big deal now it's because too
many people are using dark mode
like the brightness in your life I go to
my Better Health session
after I lost my job and I use my
three-month coupon uh it's remittance no
it's because it's because people are
using light mode to substitute for some
social media that's why I'm trying to
grow like a planet
[Applause]
feel the cells getting energy in my body
photosynthesis please don't be like a
cannabis plant bro trying to grow from
artificial life for this house
oh my God